it's good to you know keep things in
perspective you may believe that your
life is difficult but you should realize
that there are people out there who face
struggles and obstacles hardships and
persecution
far beyond what you have ever known or
will ever experience
uh you've been through your own trials
perhaps but at least your life
hasn't been as hard on you as it has
been
on michelle obama the former first lady
who graduated from two ivy league
schools became first lady by the age of
45
is now worth a combined 135 million
dollars along with her husband
has always been eager to talk about the
many ways in which this country has
oppressed her
she returned to that theme in a recent
interview with cbs telling the outlet
that
she quote lived in fear or lives in fear
and is afraid of getting randomly gunned
down by the cops while
shopping for groceries or walking her
dog apparently the fact that she gets
secret service protection everywhere she
goes is not enough to make her feel
secure
she considers it plausible that a racist
cop might run up and
execute a former first lady on the spot
for no reason
obama is also concerned that her
daughters will get racially profiled
while driving
she lies awake at night tossing and
turning fearing that some police
officers
police officer with a professional death
wish will harass the famous daughters of
a united states president
these are all very real fears that she
has and don't ever doubt these fears
don't doubt them here she is describing
them many of us still
live in fear as we go to the grocery
store or
worry about our dogs walking our dogs or
allowing our children to get a license i
mean just imagine
aren't your girls driving they're
driving but every time they get in a car
by themselves
i worry about what assumption is being
made by somebody who doesn't know
everything about them the fact that they
are good students
and polite girls but maybe they're
playing their music a little loud maybe
somebody sees the back of their head
and makes an assumption i like so many
parents black kids have to that the the
innocent act of getting a license puts
fear in our hearts um so
i think i think we have to talk about it
more and we have to ask
our fellow citizens to listen a bit more
and to believe us yeah just to be clear
again
when she talks about being afraid of
walking down the street or you know
walking her dog or
going to the grocery store that is what
she's saying she's saying she's afraid
that a cop will shoot her
that's the claim being made by michelle
obama michelle obama is afraid that a
cop
will shoot her she says
and why won't someone listen to her she
asks you know they just need to listen
to us
yes why won't someone listen to michelle
obama michelle obama is tired of being
ignored
she wrote a book that sold 10 million
copies in five months
clearly nobody cares what she has to say
nobody is listening to her
it's just as clear that only black
parents have to worry about their kids
behind the wheel
white parents have no such concern you
know when i was 17 and i got my license
and i went out on the roads
my parents were they were sleeping easy
it was no problem
weren't worried at all we white parents
simply cannot conceive
of living a life as difficult as that of
a beloved
multi-millionaire celebrity who charges
two hundred thousand dollars to give a
45-minute speech
can't even we can't wrap our heads
around it
if you're not yet convinced that
michelle obama is a victim and that her
bitterness towards this country is
warranted
i need only remind you of a segment from
her podcast a few months ago
where she talked about the racism she
experienced even while in the white
house
what you're about to hear is very
difficult to listen to it'll send
chills down your spine um but it is your
responsibility to confront this because
this is what is happening
to michelle obama you're not going to be
able to you're not going to believe this
listen
[Music]
so i'm standing there with two little
black girls another
black female adult they're in soccer
uniforms
and a white woman cuts right in front of
us
to order like she didn't even see us
and i liter and the the girl behind the
counter
almost took her order and i said excuse
me
i think you don't see us four people
standing right here you just jumped in
line
she didn't apologize she never looked me
in my
eye she didn't know it was me all she
saw was
a black person or a group of black
people or maybe she didn't even see that
what white folks don't understand it's
like that
that is so telling of how
white america views people who are not
like them
you know we don't exist
[Music]
she doesn't exist someone noticed
michelle obama she's not being noticed
you heard that right michelle obama
years later specifically remembers
one time when someone cut in front of
her in line and is still complaining
about it
who can blame her i mean obviously this
was racism there could be
no other explanation someone cut in
front of her in line
and she you know by the way remember
before she was talking about don't make
assumptions about people
she jumped to the she assumed that this
person is racist
that's the assumption she made but but
it's it's it's uh
she she can make that assumption because
it's not as though
all humans on the face of this planet
have had similar experiences
it's not as though line cutters are
globally reviled
precisely because we've all encountered
this many times
no this is michelle obama's cross to
carry
just think about this michelle obama was
delayed in getting ice cream for upwards
of 15
seconds 15 seconds imagine
she could have starved her children
could have starved
all because they're black now lest you
think that michelle obama is the only
fabulously wealthy famous and beloved
black celebrity
to be persecuted by this country i must
also remind you of lebron james
lebron net worth 500 million dollars
who's been a millionaire athlete since
the age of 18 and was nationally
acclaimed even before that it would be
accurate to say that lebron
has been a celebrated and nationally
recognized athlete for the vast majority
of his life
almost his entire life going back into
childhood
but even so lebron has suffered the sort
of maltreatment that the average white
man cannot comprehend the nba
the nba star has like michelle often
claim to be too afraid to walk down the
street
despite being surrounded by armed
security living in a multi-million
dollar mansion in a posh
los angeles suburb lebron is worried
that some crazed racist cop will run up
and shoot him dead
such a thing has literally never
happened
nothing like that has ever happened but
he's worried that it will
and his fear should be validated in
fairness lebron
has experienced hate crimes in the past
um
who can forget the time when lebron
claimed that someone spray-painted the
n-word
somewhere on his property now in fact i
say who can forget
everyone has forgotten but um he did
actually claim this
and he spoke out against the hate crime
courageously was applauded by the media
now the funny thing is that the cops
showed up to investigate
and they never found any racist graffiti
it had been
painted over already nothing strange
about that calling the cops to
investigate
graffiti but painting over it before
they arrive
who could question that the media
certainly didn't question it
and what about oprah winfrey net worth
2.7 billion dollars
she especially in recent years has taken
to denouncing white privilege as well
now sure she has more wealth and power
than the average white person could
could hope to accrue in 10 000 lifetimes
but the average white
white person still has something that
oprah winfrey doesn't
whiteness what is whiteness worth
what can you cash it in for well that
isn't explained exactly but the point is
that
if you're a white man living in a 900
square foot modular home
and feeding your children canned tuna
for dinner tonight
you are more privileged than oprah
winfrey as she explains here
there are white people who are not as
powerful as
the system of white people the caste
system that's been put in place
but they still no matter where they
are on the wrong or the ladder of
success
they still have their whiteness they
still have
their whiteness that's what you say to
the guy
feeding the kids tuna in the modular
home you have your whiteness
you got that at least can't afford
medical bills but you have your
whiteness
cash that in cash that in at the cosmic
prize counter
maybe it'll be good for a couple jolly
ranchers and a chinese finger trap
imagine being oprah i mean it must be so
hard
that's why oprah was the perfect person
to speak to and commiserate with
meghan markle who's uh sort of black but
fully persecuted
a hollywood actress turned royalty
turned media mogul
um and it's unclear why she was
deserving of any of those titles at all
being that she has no talent to speak of
whatsoever but
surely she has known troubles and
tribulations that a white mother
waitressing at a denny's
never has or never will likewise for
sean p
diddy combs who penned an open letter to
corporate mayor america a few weeks ago
blasting the corporate world for
discriminating against people like
himself
now sean combs is worth 900 million
dollars
despite the fact that he's never
produced anything of value in his entire
life
uh he's been a millionaire since his
early 20s
that's also when he killed tupac
allegedly but none of that can erase the
pain
caused by the unspecified corporate
villains who have caused him
unspecified harm who knows maybe he
could be worth one billion already if
not for that discrimination
can you imagine that can you imagine
not being a billionaire that's the sort
of reality that sean
combs has to face every day at least for
a few more years until he actually is a
billionaire
all of this raises the question when
will america
finally become the sort of country where
black people can succeed
or at least i mean succeed more succeed
more than being millionaires and
billionaires and some of the most famous
and powerful people
in the country that's the question
in closing i want to give you a
statistic that will shock you
to your core and you're not going to
believe this but it's true
did you know that there are today
no black trillionaires
none not one
not even oprah still think white
privilege is a myth
[Music]
well clearly you're wrong well i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content